la balanza para definir el próximo
presidente de francia la inclinarán los
votantes de la izquierdista de humala
son
yo creo que eso puede pasar por una
sencilla razón si uno mira la política
el programa de
acción usted mira que hay mucha
coincidencia con lópez en cuestiones del
azote de la salida de la otan y todas
esas cosas hace que los votantes podían
inclinar por lepe pero hay una cosa
también que es muy importante por dentro
estuve en francia hace dos días que las
personas sobre todo los jóvenes miran al
pp sobre todo en su programa donde en
cuestiones de deuda de un estudio que
ellos pueden inclinar muchísimo hacia
lepe aunque el epen no gana esta
elección también yo creo que es una
victoria para ellos por la derecha por
lo que le han ido muy bien en estas
elecciones y según lo que usted nos dice
la consulta de la francia insumisa sirve
como una previsión de lo que serán las
votaciones del domingo y que tanto
afectarán los resultados que vimos hoy
en el llamado voto útil
es lo mismo casi yo puedo estar mirando
esto haciendo la misma análisis que
estaban viendo en eeuu durante las
elecciones 20 donalson y la de click con
entonces hay una máquina normalmente en
en las elecciones donde lo sé lo sé como
los pronósticos pueden dar a un
candidato como lo pasó en eeuu la
sorpresa yo no digo que le tenga ganar
en las elecciones porque la diferencia
de 10 es de 6 a 4 puntos eso no queda
mucho en su favor pero puede llegar a
confundir que puede llegar a como
equivocar las políticas